[Music]
[Applause]
greetings ladies and
gentlemen Live From The
Improv
[__] I'm here to do a tip [__] 15
for you ladies and gentlemen uh
no no that's a lie that's a lie in the
name of trying to make you laugh I'm
gonna do a loose
180 very
loose welcome kids to fat man beyond I'm
Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard
hey
oh uh I am in New Jersey above a movie
theater I am in Southern California in
an office slash uh like guess the the
scare floor yeah look at you monstr
Inc um the uh Mike
wasowski back hello wasowski my kid was
little when Monsters Inc came out my God
that was such a big factor in our
house told this story before but like
you know the Pixar was like hey will you
give us a quote for an Oscar ad and I
was like yeah as if [__] Oscar voters
listen to me what am I Damen chazelle
and so uh I gave him some quote and as a
thank you they sent me the giant Sully
and Mike that used to be in movie
theaters oh [__] three dimensional made
of like thick styrofoam with real fur on
it and [__] like
that so I was like oh my God these are
astounding and um we unpacked them from
these giant crates and put them in
Harley's room Harley was like three at
the
time and uh you know I was like oh my
god when she [__] walks in a room
she's gonna pass the [__] out man this
is like this is
unbelievable kid comes in the room and
she's just like wow and then goes and
does a zillion other
things that's when I realized oh I was
like Wow because I grew up [__] poor
this kid grew up you know
with stuff so to her it wasn't like oh
my God this is the greatest thing that
ever happened to me to her it was just
like oh San micer here of
course is that is that a like jaded from
privilege or just the three-year-old
imagination she's like of course my
friends are here there is no dividing
line between imaginary and real the very
next thing she said Mark was uh I want a
pony now daddy
now
ask an answer counselor she was just um
you know she had honestly like she had
big stuffed downal she had a big like
stuffed uh teddy bear that we called
Charlie Quinn that Joe Casada and Nancy
Casada uh gave us before the kid was
born was huge so she was used to like
big things I guess in her room but these
things were [__] huge honestly I felt
like insanely successful when I saw
those crates at my house I was like what
popped it open I was like I'm I've done
it
like that was my oscar moment right
there brought to you by the Oscar close
as all ofg and and I probably love them
more um how's everybody doing
kids forgot they can't [__] respond
uh me and Mark coming at you all over
your face neck and chest and [__] B man
probably popping in from time to time as
well that your cute
you no he's off mik we're
we're Flying Blind on a rocket cycle
there he is how you doing there bamp man
I'm okay I uh I'll tell you what's weird
my two-year-old daughter is obsessed
with Nightmare Before
Christmas well that's twoy old daughter
has good [__] taste not
scared like we're going to bed and Oogie
Boogie is my friend is what she's
saying crazy bro take take that kid to
Hot Topic or head will
[__] yeah take it to the Bowl take it to
the bowl for uh for the The Nightmare
Before Christmas concert and who is it
this year I read it's like Hy
alternating with uh kathern
O'Hara s will be no Paul Rubin uh Danny
Elfman of course
he's him and every one of his [__]
10,000 muscles will squeeze into
Hollywood Bow that guy's [__] ripped
now man yolked senior citizen holy [__]
and he is a senior citizen like he's
[__] 70 years yeah but like gez man
the old people today don't look like the
old people of my youth do you remember
when when JK Simmons was working out to
play Commissioner Gordon and Gordon and
he had [__] guns what are you doing I
was like that's that that and Harvey
Bullock are two of the only Parts don't
have to get beefed up man he was [__]
he too was just like look at the gun
show and
[__] close your eyes Batman because the
gun
show yeah Gary oldman's on an all scone
diet meanwhile JK Simmons is here just
[__]
shredding um you know go just looking
back so that movie's 30 years old which
is insane but I I was doing trivia the
other night at the bar and uh I do a
category that I call three actors and a
year and so I'll give three actors in
the year and you have to tell me what
movie it is and I did a movie from 19
1990 through
1999 um and I was like man the '90s had
a lot of great movies and and the bar
giggled at me as if like as if I was
being funny or something like the like
the 90s movies sucked so I looked up
movies of just 1993 you know how many M
great movies are turning or at least
entertaining movies are turning Jurassic
Park Schindler's List Robin Hood Men and
tights Demolition Man Groundhog Day True
Romance Dazed and Confused The Sandlot
The Firm mask of the
fantasm Mrs Doubtfire The Fugitive in
the line of fire Hocus Pocus Tombstone
What's Eating Gilbert Grape Caro's way
Cone Heads falling down Nightmare Before
Christmas that's like 20
of like every weekend there was a movie
that came out that you wanted to see
that's better than like the last
decade and Cone Heads that is yeah and
con heads that is the uh that's all the
mov movies that were playing right
before like uh I took clerks to
Sundance then because then in 94 like
clerks we're coming up on 2024 man right
now we just
passed October 3D the 30th anniversary
of clerk's going to the iffm the
independent feature film Market where we
thought like we're dead nobody's gonna
see this movie and then that's where the
ball started rolling because Bob Hawk
saw a flick um so that means January is
the 30th anniversary of us going to
Sundance with
clerks um so right now I've been making
films for 30 years but we're coming up
on the 30th anniversary of like the
world
knowing at the end of the 2024 in
October it's the 30th anniversary of the
release of the movie so naturally you
know don't don't think for a second I'm
not going to be [__] like 30 years
Clerks all year long and [__] are you
taking are you taking the 4:30 movie to
Sundance I'm hoping man I hope I mean I
hope that's up to Sundance hopefully we
get to show it to him in the next week
or two because I got a cut together for
those that don't follow that closely I
just finished making a movie called The
430 movie um I got a a sag waiver kids
so we were shooting and um hopefully
it's cut it's all pretty much cut
together um JC's seen it JC what think I
love it uh I've been working on stuff
with you since since you finished Red
State I joined up with you when you were
touring Red State and I think this is I
loved clerks 3 but I think this is my
favorite movie we've worked on a man
thank you and actually Jason what's that
am I good in
it I don't even
remember you in it uh but it's funny
because I and I'm not saying that
because I'm like well my voice is in it
like it was clerks I wasn't even there
like I started on the movie after you
were like hey I'm done with it here uh
so it's uh I love it I'm excited for
everybody to see
it ah me too man it turned out uh really
really sweet it's very sweet very very
um dreamy little
picture um JC before it
like like referen the sand lot and I was
like not not
wrong it it's not I mean not like
plot-wise or anything but right in terms
of like how it makes you
feel
ni uh
um but yeah that was uh why did that
come up again Big
Year big year yeah that's 30 years of
[__]
clerks um 30 years of Clerks and this
jerk um so all year long don't forget
kids we're gonna be cramming that in
your [__]
face a gonna let you forget is that a f
is that a is that a super chat in in the
chat um are we back to that sort of
thing oh no JC oh that's that wasn't me
somebody else turned that
on I didn't do it I didn't break that
lamp I swear eventually that's will
Wilkins will Wilkins is like let's dial
it up he's like no sponsor tonight
so um the uh kids we got a show for you
kind of look at this I got a table that
goes up and down
ready this the elevator this how yeah
I'll be back in a minute I gotta go get
to the wine
[Laughter]
seller um what uh what are we gonna talk
about with these folks let's give them a
preview um well we uh each of us has now
seen two episodes of the Loki show
season two the Loki show I wish it was
called the Loki show yes the Loki show
brought to you by Proctor and Gamble and
Patriot brand
cigarettes um there's some New York
ComicCon news um that will sort of fold
into our standard news Gathering
LDA um there's some some plugs that I
think both of us are going to want to
make about events Andor products coming
down the pike true um and then there's
there's this [__] News man news
um I am back East because we just had
the SM Castle fil
Festival uh this last weekend um it
opened on Thursday night with uh sa
Rogers chasing Chasing Amy then
continued through Friday Saturday Sunday
we did Awards and it was absolutely
lovely second annual SM Castle Film
Festival um and looks like we'll be
doing a third of course and then I was
going to head home but um there's
another thing that I'm doing out here on
Thursday which is JC can you throw up
that link the friends of
firefighters Gala benefit uh this is the
organization um that grew out of uh the
September 11th attacks and after
September 11th attacks we had a bunch of
First Responders and folks who you know
were dealing with uh
the mental health issues and physical
health issues and whatnot so this
organization wonderful organization
called friends of firefighters um that
Bushi is a member of as well Steve
Bushi um they're doing their fundraising
Gala on Thursday in Brooklyn and so I'm
the MC they're also full disclosure
giving me some sort of award which is
very sweet of them so I'm in town uh for
that b man do you did I I sent that link
can you throw that up I I'm working on
it it uh it's requiring me to log in so
I I'll have it up in two seconds keep
keep keep chatting no worries whatsoever
um that's what I'm doing on uh Thursday
so that's kept me out here and then
Friday I'll head back back West um to
the land of Los Angeles how you been
what you've been up to you know man it's
been uh it's been a good couple of weeks
I guess since the last time we did this
maybe it was last week the last time we
did it maybe to talk about the first
episode of Loki in the finale of Ahsoka
I think had to be last week yeah had to
be last week um you know kind of work is
beginning to heat up you know now that
the WJ strike is over now that
development is starting a new there's
there's the smell of uh of opportunity
is in the air so I'm [__] out there
shaking my ass the track like one does
um had a comic book announced at New
York ComicCon this uh this past weekend
um I uh JC is so busy logging into
Instagram there it is look at
you uh I on the heels of the Darth Vader
uh short story that I did for their
Anthology Darth Vader black white and
red they asked me if I wanted to write a
miniseries about mace Wu and I said yes
I do I don't know I'm GNA I don't know
I'm what I'm gonna make W do do but I'll
figure that [__] out
um they would not let me just uh reenact
Pulp Fiction with mace
Wu they they actually expected some sort
of story could you keep this kind of in
the universe I was like okay but can he
say [__] a lot like no I'm
afraid he can't the false [__]
do you wield it like no you can't do
that you can't do that look at you man
that's two Star Wars stories you got to
write I know it's been fun it's been fun
kid who like [__] saw Star Wars when
when he was
a just a youngster in [__] shortpants
running around dreaming dreaming about
sci-fi and [__] geeking out before he
found Star Trek he's like me The Little
Rascals PE p p and then one day you get
to grow up to [__] do this and get
notes from [__] Lucas film I'm sure
right like yeah man somebody makes sure
that you're not like you know and then
ma Wu pulls out a giant cocktail like oh
no he doesn't yeah Star Wars
censor does Yoda look like a [__]
Anakin then why are you trying to [__]
him 1994 great year for
movies
indeed that's tremendous congratulations
to you my friend thank you that comes
out in January four issues of Mace windy
goodness at you man next up [__]
they'll just hand you one of them star
Wars TV series that keep giving out to
everybody would you like to do a star
war yes I
would can I make this one good
though um flu 1775 in chat says D does
marcelus Wallace look like a
Sith that is very I know the puns they
just which lightsaber is yours the one
who says bad [__] on it Michael
ochre in chat says doesn't Kevin look a
little high I wish
no it's tired I was drinking some
Celsius that's my new [__] speed
right here
man you got one I got mine you got a
grape I got a grape look at that gra AE
it's a free ad right there they're not
pay I poured mine into a little cup that
has ice in it so I can just make it last
longer you pretending you're at a party
I'm going get get your red [__] Solo
Cup and
[__] some some some Celsius pong
yeah I haven't been to the movies much
lately because you know it's it's a bit
of a dirth of the movie theater unless
you're a Taylor Swift fan in which case
yeah now's your time yeah oh my good
Lord that was playing here at SM Castle
right downstairs congruent with the SM
Castle Film Festival so you had a bunch
of c easts and a bunch of tween girls um
raing theaters at the same time yeah
look I'm no I'm I'm not a Swifty and not
by virtue of the fact like I don't like
her music I just I know one song and you
know I like it but um but I respect what
she got going on and [__] clearly very
talented she's also a writer I respect
the [__] out of that but as an exhibitor
Mark as a movie theater owner oh let me
tell you I like this girl very much ER
Greta Gerwig [__] Chris Nolan these
are my favorite people Chris
Pratt both the Mario Brothers these are
my favorite people this year when it
comes to film
exhibition um so she did a solid by
shooting that [__] flick man she
didn't have to do that did you have a
like a like a a plethora of teenage
girls dancing in your theater yeah I
popped my head in one of the theaters at
one point and oh my God they shot the
[__] out of this movie Man like
literally 35 cameras there was so many
[__] Cuts where it's like bang bang
bang it's not like four cameras and
they're cutting the for an angles there
were [__] cameras
everywhere she looked like she was
having a real good time up on that St
I'm sure counting every [__] billion
of her billions of dollars and stuff do
you think
that watches like the Taylor Swift movie
and goes like you know what when I shot
the last Walts I had three [__]
cameras I
know um yeah it's uh from what I saw
when I was standing there watching I
also watched a few minutes of Paw
Patrol got thoughts I have notes um
the the dogs don't act like that Mark
I've got two dogs they don't [__] act
like that no not too much that uh but
when I sat in for a few minutes on the
Taylor SP F because you can do that when
you the movie theater um it it seemed
joyous and the kids were having a good
time that were there to see it you know
like little girls when like six seven
eight year old girls get up and dance
they're just like they stand up and like
just they know how to dance that's I sat
the theater I was like you can't dance
sit down I
said they're just like the the wavy
things outside of car ships
yes getting rid them
it was lovely though um seeing the kids
uh and uh their parents of course just
like we something to do we yeah we'll be
in the back on our phones you kids have
fun um but uh yeah man I also watched
today Jen and I went downstairs and
watched dumb
money the movie about the GameStop
scandal or not
GameStop
uh what do they call that uh I don't
know starring uh Pete Davidson St stock
incident yeah uh with Paul Dano Pete
Davidson shylene Woodley Seth
[Music]
Rogan good movie directed by Craig
Gillespie uh good flick nobody's they
didn't have a way to Market it got like
great cast but once again
and you know we're in the midst of a
strike still so they can't be out there
talking about it and stuff yeah I
suppose we can we can deliver a tiny sag
strike update I am not nearly as
informed about the SAG strike as I was
the wga strike because let's let's
finish off the wga strike they signed we
all signed everything done and we were
we all ratified the the contract that's
presented by
99% of the members who voted voted to
ratify there were some 1% 90 people were
like [__] this deal and uh and didn't
vote for it but that's a a very very
Teensy Min minority of the majority and
so writers are back to work writers
rooms are up and running um there's
there's still an open debate where those
writers rooms are um because there are
some showrunners who do not want to
cross a picket line and so the offices
that used to be on Studio lots that are
actively picketed by by sag like I won't
cross that line give me know give me Wei
work somewhere give me a give me an
office in the the back of his Staples
but I don't want to cross that line but
if you were working you're back to work
um if you were not working you're back
to looking for work and so that's the
that's the deal that's where it is and
sag I think is on day they're in the
high 80s of their strike they they have
been going great guns I believe with the
studios um they were meeting every other
day um with with the negotiating team
the the negotiations committee on behalf
of sag and then the the studio heads I
think they had four or five legit Studio
heads in the room um and I think that
some of it was the reason they were
meeting every other day is because the
actors because sag had some 30 or so
maybe even 40 points of contention like
here are are the deal points we want to
address whereas the writer really only
had eight or nine and so you could
digest that information overnight where
if you've got to go through a phone book
of of asks and counters and uh and
negotiations that takes time but as of
last week the studi walked away from the
table again um you know for reasons that
nobody can ever seem to understand other
than they're trying to split the the
membership of the union and cause some
internal disarray uh it's the same thing
they did with the writers it doesn't
work um but it's their playbook and so
they they keep on running it and much
like with the wrers when we got to day
148 and made a deal uh that could have
been made in 3 days the actors are
beginning to feel the same way which is
you know you're going to make a deal you
know you're GNA have to give a bit and
will have to give a bit um but this
weird political you know counter
intelligent scop [__] of like let's
let's just walk away let's take our game
and go home is not advantageous for
anybody so um they are cruising up on
100 days um and I've been walking the
line
like you know once maybe twice a week
I'll I'll grab my wga and support of sag
picket sign and I'll walk out there and
uh you know Spirits are still high but
somehow the lines don't feel as deep as
I would have expected for a guild the
size of sag so you're an actor out there
does it feel like that's going
to close or end soon I know they walked
away this week but like maybe that's why
people aren't walking the line so much I
mean it it what you'd hope is that it
would encourage them to to come out in
force you know it would have the
opposite effect it's like oh they walked
away fine we will show them how strong
we are by giving it a strong show of
solidarity on the lines and get out
there and and March um it has to be over
soon because what's going to end up
happening is the writers are back to
work and they're writing the scripts
that the actors would shoot and so the
hope is if you're going to save
you know winter
2024 then you need to start shooting
before Thanksgiving of 2023 which means
the actors will need a deal so doesn't
feel like you can go on for that much
longer if the studios want to save the
fiscal year uh next year um but who
knows they don't seem to be always
operating logically Brazil 201 in chat
says in New York the lines are massive
but I don't know why La isn't popping
I don't know either I mean and it's not
even that it's theater actors because
they can be working um but maybe it's
because New York only has a couple of
picket locations they're not quite
spread as thin but you know the wga's
membership was
some 100 11 12,000 people and sag is
about 160,000 people so it feels like
that's a lot of people who could be
walking who don't seem to be walking um
meanwhile on the right Guild side
everyone's going back to work we've we
the thing we were working on before
months ago before the strike happened we
get to go start resuming discussions
about yeah yeah the the world is
beginning to at least gently slowly
write itself and uh huh right puns and
so yeah we're going to be back at it
darudy and chat uh was wrote something
and then wrote like yeah ignore it as
usual um so that made me scroll back to
see what he's talking about and he said
or she said the actors came out for the
writers but as soon as the writers got
their deal they abandoned the actors do
you do you agree with that Mark um no
because the actors when they could work
did work um because they're
contractually obligated to do so um
there is a no sympathy strike clause in
in both Guild's contract um you can
decide not to cross a picket line and
some actors did if there was a picket
line outside their their set their
location Sun acers didn't cross it some
did and that's fine like as as to each
to their own um but as I said we're not
Crossing picket lines we're going back
to work because again our contract
requires us to um but we're not going to
cross a line and go back to work on the
Warner Brothers lot or on the Disney lot
that's that's what the picket does um so
there's that that
weirdness the disconnect I suppose on
what some people saw and did during The
Writers Guild strike you know there were
actors who walked on the lines with us
who were also working you know but they
walked because they believed in what we
were doing but had to do their jobs
because they signed a contract requiring
them to do that job same with us in chat
Gwen said wjga and sag are in solidarity
no one as abandon anyone correct we are
supporting as much as we can
support um shall we dive into the news
because people are starting to ask
questions that are kind of news related
for example Dwayne Atley is asking is
NBC Universal going to buy Warner
Brothers is that in the news do you have
anything about that um it is it is a
rumor um it is not a thing that is in
motion but you know the the belief had
always been that the way David zaslov
has been treating Warner Brothers
Discovery has been you know trimming the
fat for an eventual sale to somebody um
getting all of their tax burdens in line
you know shrinking the
workforce minimizing their taxes all of
that stuff killing movies that maybe
people should have seen is all in an
effort to to make the company more
attractive to a buyer um and the theory
the theory seems to be is well who could
for to buy Warner Brothers and there's
about a handful of people who could then
NBC Universal is one of them um as is
Apple if they wanted to as is Amazon if
they wanted to um um but there's no
there's no current like negotiations in
that regard but you know it it is not by
any stretch out of the realm of
possibility that in the next few years
um even though we have antitrust laws
that seem to be maybe guidelin and not
laws anymore that giant companies buying
giant companies to form another giant
Voltron company is probably not a great
idea um but nobody seems to care so I
guess that's what's gonna happen George
DD in chat says I can guarantee you the
NBC would not get the sign off from the
government to buy Warner he probably
right too big right I mean Disney got
the sign off to buy
Fox yeah good point Amazon got the sound
off to buy MGM
like everything is
possible
bam hey man what up B man C can I ask uh
as writers is people who have to work in
this industry does it really worry you
guys when it's like well I have two
employers it's either NBC Universal or
it's Disney or or I guess three or it's
Apple because if you piss one person off
not that I have any experience pissing
off one of those corporations in any way
shape or form but all of a sudden you
can't work with any of the other ones so
like nothing Marvel will have anything
to do with scum and villainy
nothing uh at all so is that I mean is
that really what the fear is of just
like well
you know I do work with Hollywood
Reporter if I fall out with Hollywood
Reporter I also fall out with like dead
spin Rolling Stone
billboard uh variety
variety you know it's just like well
that's it like if you work in
entertainment journalism it's like
Entertainment Weekly and Pensky media
like is
that is that just a giant fear is that
just about controlling the N completely
controlling the narrative Charles Foster
Kane is that where we're at I mean it's
it's it's not good because as a as a
person who sells things you want lots of
places to be able to sell that thing
yeah and if suddenly what used to be
eight places buying becomes seven
becomes six becomes five that's less
opportunities to sell the thing you know
like when you used you used to be able
to pitch you know Disney proper used to
be able to pitch Fox proper you know you
used to be able to pitch [__]
lucasfilm proper or Pixar proper they
were all buyers of things and then once
they all get under the same corporate
you know umbrella that's less ability
for you to find the market for what
you're selling and it's not great so if
it all comes down to ultimately two
companies left then you know sure
they'll still make stuff and sure some
of those Executives at Fox search light
have a budget to buy stuff but it's not
as if they didn't have to deal with some
giant corporate Synergy initiative they
could just [__] go out on the L and I
believe in this let's do that it's not
as easy anymore so yeah I'm I'm not
gonna say I'm deeply afraid of it the
way I am of like spiders but it's not
it's not a healthy business environment
to not have a healthy Marketplace
spiders
antitrust keeping me out of
work
one of those things is always closer
than the
other um the chat is full of people
wanting to talk about stuff like the a24
pivot you read about that no what's
their pivot they also want to talk about
Best Buy announcing they're done with
physical media start yeah the a24 pivot
to like we want Blockbuster filmmakers
which a24 I guess is uh looking for more
IP properties
um you know
because you know not every not every
movie is everything everywhere all at
once I mean if I'm an a24 executive I
start like shopping and sifting through
public domain like I start saying like
what's our version of The Little Mermaid
what's a a24 movie that that's [__]
Winnie the Poop which is not public
domain right you know like rather than
in instead of shopping for like give us
you know [__] I mean I who knows what
this is just a report that was in the
press that they're like yeah we're open
to or they've been taking meetings about
meeting with about doing bigger things
looking for bigger properties and
whatnot and that's got folks scared
online because they're like no it was a
good small perfect thing I guess in
short Mark Bo is afraid
uh and B is the internet and the
internet's afraid that the modern day
mirax
a24 the uh the most interesting film
Distribution Company currently in the
business uh is going to become somehow
less interesting I say no I don't think
that's necessarily going
to mean that they're going to stop
making all the movies they've made
they're just also trying to get hits so
that they can continue
making the weirdness that's what I hope
I mean I think they've they've figured
out you know they're one of the
few um production companies that has an
aesthetic like you know an a24 movie
when you see it which it feels a lot
like HBO used to be in the early 2000s
it's not TV it's HBO and you knew an HBO
show when you when you watched it and so
is there a way to scale up what a24
means like yeah there there absolutely
is in the same way that Miramax would do
tiny [__] movies nobody ever heard of
and then a crime game and then Pulp
Fiction and then you know we'll spend
some money and we'll we'll make a thing
that nobody else would make that's all
that means then hey go for it be the
Blum House of Art House um feels like a
decent way to go um and Best Buy uh I
guess has announced that they're done
with physical media as of the first of
the year so Christmas this is it for
like you know that's why I was doing
those [__] tremendous steelbox
for various Blu-rays and some old some
new but they're getting out of physical
media man which means the price of that
shit's going to go up don't mean it's
goingon to go away kids there'll still
be people making stuff it's just but now
can't offset the cost with you know like
a couple pallets going off
to to Best Buy so probably means per
unit cost of of physical media you know
that we Blu-rays and whatnot will
probably go up a little bit but it
doesn't mean the end of it never going
away it's like records man there's
always gonna [__] do you know how many
vhs's people bring me now and F because
now you can also get those authenticated
and
slabbed SE old vhs's that have never
been open that still have like the logo
on the [__] rap like Bo of to home
video or MCA Universal or something like
that um so yeah they'll always be
physical media kids but Best Buy
dropping out of the game is it's a shame
it's a
blow it is you know and I think that
especially as people begin to realize
that there was a convenience and a
permanence to physical media that you do
not get in a streaming environment when
like you had it you had it nobody could
take it away nobody could unlicense it
from it from you nobody could come in
your house and decide you know what you
don't get to watch Robocop anymore
because we've not sold the rights to
another streamer and so it's not on this
one the one you had a subscription to if
it's in your house you can watch it um
and you know I think that people are
beginning to to remember how uh what it
was like to be a collector and that
there was some joy to be had in there
like [__] Criterion had a wicked sale
today did you did you see this 50% off
every Criterion disc um for 24 hours and
I went a little [__] nuts for a dude
who doesn't currently have a job and
almost spent like $200 buying Criterion
today look you give me these
Blu-rays give me these
Blu-rays um so yeah it's it's I think
you're right I think it'll become like
records I think it'll become a a a not
even bespoke but way more of a ob based
collector's medium and like yeah you
might end up spending 50 bucks for a DVD
um you want it our friend Josh
mundall on in a Super Chat asked us
Kevin did you receive the Gil
Gerard uh Buck Rogers DVD box set yeah
he had gifted me that I did receive that
thank you very much it inspired you to
create a ranger danger comic or an
animated series yet to p p PCH to
Netflix um no but there's something in
the 430 movie that is in that Buck
Rogers realm uh thank you Josh you're
very very sweet man it's a $20 Super
Chat right there my
friend $20 Super Chat D that's that's
good for a good dozen csuses that's true
me and Mark buy the drink that won't
sponsor us nope
to be fair we didn't ask hey speaking of
sponsor or speaking of [__] you can buy
if you go to a website
called um what's that website called
Mercantile Instinct that's Malcolm
Ingram's website you can buy the clerk
Blu-ray my life documentary about my
life with this awesome little sleeve
that goes over it this o-ring is they
call it in the
business uh go to mertile instinct.
right now get your copy of
clerk um what else can we talk about you
got
news um well uh we could get into the
Loki of it all and then hit the news or
we could just dive into the news Well
actually the first news item does dovea
very nicely into Loki so we can do that
yeah let's do it I watched episode
two as did I story in progress nice to
see e Eevee back
um you know give me a few more
episodes I uh I I caught up with the
first episode and watched the second
episode and I have no idea what's
happening really like it's been a long
time since season one and so like
pruning of of timelines and sacred
timeline and TVA This and like it's it's
all swimming a little bit over my head
um but I also don't care that much
because I just very much like watching
Tom Heston and Owen Wilson kind of just
banter like the two of them together is
fun to watch and so I'll just watch that
and like the story will eventually begin
to make sense and you add KIU Kuan to
that who's just adorable um you know
like it's it's it's perfectly amiable
viewing even though I don't know yet
what the story is you know episode one
ends with we got to find Sylvie okay why
because we just have to we need to know
what and and cuz she things happened at
the end of the universe and the man who
shall not be named or whatever okay yeah
let's G do that and we're gonna spend
some time in a in an Old McDonald's yeah
right cool that's also fun you know like
I just I don't get it yet but maybe I'm
not supposed to or maybe as the internet
is fond of saying I'm not smart enough
to get it same but it's also it speaks
volumes about the charm of that
cast it's like I'll take your journey
because I like watching these people and
I'm not sure where you guys are going
just yet and I wish you'd get there a
lot
sooner but uh yeah it continues to Pace
um and still insanely wellmade and well
acted um but you know as we've learned
this week or last week uh Marvel is
doing something of a retcon when it
comes to
their TV shows is that the story that
Dove tells ni that is the lead story
this week my friend it's everywhere that
story man yeah that was broken in the in
The Hollywood Reporter uh written by our
man Boris kid um Marvel slams the brakes
on Daredevil and then discovers how
television
Works
um that uh yeah they were making an 18
episode daredevil show dar double born
again um they had paused production in
mid June um during the writer strike um
they had shot about Nine episodes of it
of the 18 um but apparently it was
enough for Marvel Executives including
Kevin flagy to review the footage and
Come Away with a clear-eyed assessment
the show wasn't
working uh so in late September this
year Marvel quietly let go of head
writers Chris Orton Matt
pman uh
oh there's a thought in chat that I'm
like
wow Taylor in chat says it'll be awesome
if Short Round is the new he who
remains
okay could be right because right now
he's like an innocent adorable lovable
little character but maybe by the end
he's a Kang be anyway back to Daredevil
um so yes the marvelous on the hunt for
new writers to oversee I suppose writing
a whole new show and using some of what
had already been
shot but it's all of that is
increasingly unclear what exactly is
happening um inside the the house of
ideas um you know according to and you
know CHR had some quotes from people on
the record like Brad windbound who's the
head of streaming television animation
for and saying we're trying to marry the
Marvel culture with the traditional
television culture it comes down to how
can we tell stories in television that
honor what's so great about the source
material um I think part of the issue
and it's a thing that is highlighted
there's a new book on stands called MCU
the reign of Marvel Studios yeah um
which is fantastic like it's a terrific
book I I I got a a look at it about a
month ago or so um and it's amazing like
it they they interview some hundred
people you know from the very beginning
of Marvel when they were set up above a
Beverly Hills Mercedes Benz dealership
all the way till now um and uh Joanna
Robinson was sort of the lead researcher
and and and I'm sorry the lead reporter
and Dave Gonzalez was the lead
researcher and one of the things they
talk about is the Marvel method of
making movies which is you know Kevin
feige would entrust a filmmaker to go
off and make the movie that they wanted
to make you know with lots of input from
the the Marvel Executives and whatever
they would build time into the
production schedule so they come back
with a movie by and Company would look
at it and see what was missing and then
go off and shoot that stuff that was
missing that's the way they've done
everything basically since ironment the
problem is that TV doesn't quite work
that way you know you actually need to
have a showrunner a writer who's in
charge who's keeping the story in their
head the entire time both on set and in
post and it's infinitely harder to
operate that way we're like oh all right
so here here's 10 hours of content you
know we now need to figure out how to
spot well this together so it makes
sense two hours is somewhat easier to do
than 10 hours 18 hours of of television
and so that seems to be the fundamental
you know flash of styles which is
television is its own Beast um
television has been made a certain way
for 50 years um and it works not to say
that you can't innovate stuff because
people are innovating the ways you make
television all the time but you know you
don't break it unless it's broken and
lots of people have made fantastic
television the way television gets made
and so from Marvel 2 now kind of come
around like oh you know
what maybe we did need uh we did need to
have showrunners maybe we did need to
involve them in the entire process maybe
we did need to have somebody uh mining
the shop at every turn um you know like
moonnight with with Oscar Isaac and
Ethan Hawk you know the Creator and
writer Jeremy Slater quit uh director
Muhammad diab took the Reigns um you
know the writer of the show was not
there Jessica G developed and wrote chog
attorney at law but was sidelined once
director Kat Coro came aboard um you
know like it's just there's there's a
Litany of these kinds of shows
especially Marvel shows that seem as if
there's just a ball being kind of handed
over to lots of different people you
know secret Invasion um pal Brad street
who was a writer and AP on on Mr Robot
had been working on the scripts for a
year when he was fired after Marvel went
a different direction then a new guy
named Brian Tucker came aboard um with a
new director and all of these pieces
just keep on moving and it's very hard
to make a good television show that way
um and so yeah like even Marvel is now
coming around to saying it's like you
know what we might need showrunners it's
a term we've not only grown comfortable
with but also learned to embrace says
Brad windbone um we need Executives that
are dedicated to this medium uh that are
going to focus on streaming and focus on
television because they and movies are
two different art forms
so we'll see what happens man but it's
it's it's a little rocky over there at
the moment and it I suppose it it helps
that all parties concerned have decided
to slow down the production process you
know Bob Iger once he returned from the
Wilderness was like we're doing too much
stuff like you're making movies you
might not need to make and there's way
too much television so let's just kind
of I read some today that said maybe
Wonderman is going away as well yeah
that's a rumor that that Wonderman which
was like 90% shot um and stopped during
the the riter strike might be just a
casualty of War might be like you know
what not going to finish
it you know Eko which has been bounced I
think into next year um which is going
to be like a Thanksgiving drop of just
here you go enjoy the binge it'll be the
first it would have been the first time
the Marvel would have binged the thing
and that does not imply an overwhelming
amount of
confidence um um well my heart goes out
to everyone that worked on that
Daredevil
um you know just like my heart went out
to everyone that worked on [__]
backgirl like could you imagine putting
all that time into something and I'm not
saying like good or bad I'm not
commenting on the quality but it's just
like you put all your time and effort
into a thing and
then you know somebody's like
nah yeah it's not working you know like
in apparently that daredevil show like
he wasn't in the suit for the first four
episodes of the show because they very
much wanted it to be like a legal
procedural it's like I mean okay but and
when I say they I mean it was you know
marvel and probably not the the writers
um that is speculation I'm sure but like
how do you not put Daredevil in the
Daredevil suit for four hours of TV
well you know Netflix the the series
didn't put him into the suit until the
literal end of the show they had him in
a you know [__] sleek black outfit
where he put a you know thing around his
eyes but he didn't get into that suit
until the second or couple episodes
toward the end if I remember correctly
did he get the mask right but he's like
in a suit doing Daredevil things right
you know look I'm I'm with you I I did
not need especially because they already
established the dude as Daredevil in
She-Hulk so it's like what are you
waiting for episodes get him in a suit
for yeah like once you cast Charlie Cox
and once you bring Vincent denafo back
and once you know John barenthal is back
like you're you're Daredevil season
three at this point so just or or I
don't remember how many they did on
Netflix they do three seasons in I think
they did three so this would be
essentially season four but they're you
know
they're it seemed like I guess maybe
they were trying to keep cost down
because you know their Daredevil bounces
around and [__] remember she jumped off
buildings and
whatnot Netflix Daredevil just kicks the
[__] out of people in a Non-Stop hallway
fight yeah yeah and like that was also
done under the the the the Marvel TV you
know the Jeff lobe era you know and more
to the point the ike PE mutter like
we're going to be as cheap as [__]
possible era and so they were never
going to spend pingy poity Daredevil
money it was always going to be gritty
and dudes in hallways um which worked it
worked that first season Daredevil is
great the first season of Jessica Jones
is great the first season of of Luke
Cage is great the first season of Iron
Fist
exists
um but yeah I don't know man I don't
know it just feels it feels like there
was it was due a change in in the
operating style for Marvel TV and it
seems
like change is going to come Silas bar
in chat said I promised this the last
time I mentioned that werewolf by night
color version showing this month
Remember by night was black and white I
guess they got a color version of yeah I
I got a chance to meet Michael Gino at a
at a birthday party um a couple weeks
back and told him how much I uh I
appreciate werewolf by
night and he seemed a he seemed a cool
cat he did a wonderful job uh all right
what else we got Yo shit's crazy on
Aquaman 2 oh my Lord
yeah my my heart goes out to
every [__] fellow DC fan man it's
just
like can't
win can't get a can't get a bite man
flash
Shazam Blue
Beetle and now are we getting Aquaman by
the end of this year or no uh we're
supposedly getting it you know I think
that that Warner Brother seems bullish
on the strike coming to an end so being
able to have Mamoa out there blacking it
but yeah like variety had this whole bit
about the Amber herd and Johnny Depp
trial document surfacing surfacing and
like all kinds of alleged behavior on
the part of mimoa who was apparently
allegedly drunk who dressed like Johnny
Depp and like he I I don't know that he
I mean I [__] I met him once on a plane
seemed like a nice guy but I I don't
don't think he just dressed like Johnny
Depp I think that's he dresses I don't
think he dressed as Johnny Depp I think
he just kind of dresses like Johnny Depp
layers and [__] like that right I mean
that's like it's it's very like he said
she said it's like you know herds people
are like this is the thing that happened
that was done intentionally to to
dispirit my client and then MIM moa's
reps are like hey he's not dressed like
Johnny Depp he's always dressed like a
Bohemian like he's always been in like
blowy things and lots of ch and rings
and whatever yes you know it's like he's
conducted himself he's a professional
all times on the set of Aquaman and the
lost kingdom does he like a drink
occasionally sure everybody does but he
doesn't show up drunk on set but like
it's like we talked about it before that
all the re-shoot years and years and
years in of re- shoots but like the more
that comes out about this thing the more
it's like what the
[__] you
know yeah I don't I don't know I I've I
saw the one thing that
like you know um that I I read in the
news
that I was like well I I guess I can
understand that was um they were having
test screenings and spoilers kids I
don't know if they're going to continue
doing this in the movie but they did
this once in the comics so spoil ERS for
that as well in the comics many years
ago Black
Manta killed Aquaman's
son the aqua baby aquad Aqualad him and
him and uh mir's baby so that's pretty
famous comic book storyline and it
sounds like they included a version of
that in this new Aquaman movie where uh
black uh Manta kills Aquaman and
mirror's baby and you know [__]
audiences walked out they were like [__]
this so I can get my head around that if
some audience is like I don't [__]
come to no superhero movie to watch a
[__] baby die but you know the comic
book guy in me was like well that's what
they did in the
comics uh so it sounds like that's
probably GNA go away it sounds like
they've been changing this movie so much
dude they had minimum two Batman in this
movie at one they had Michael Keaton
Batman and they also had [__] Ben
Affleck
Batman yeah I mean apparently the sequel
has ured challenges outside of the Amber
herd SG and was testing in the 60s
before being recut in the summer of 2022
despite the overhaul the film continued
to test in the 60s prompting another new
cut uh this movie is like the echo of
regimes says one Insider It's the Last
Remnant of the snse and no one really
wants to take ownership of it re-shoot
took place right up until this year's
wga stri in May um let's see in fact
none of the Stars caned by Zack Snyder
for Batman be Superman da of Justice and
Justice League including Ben Affleck
Henry caval Gadot Ezra Miller and Mamoa
will reprise their roles in the new DC
Universe in character Mamoa May return
just not as Aquaman sources say the
actors engage in talks to play Lobo
either in the 2025 reboot Superman
Legacy or in a standalone film that
honestly
makes absolute sense to me yeah he looks
like
Lobo yeah you know and like if you're
gonna get a new Superman you kind of
have to get a new everybody else anyway
like and if you want a clean start if
you wanna the DC Universe begins here
all of that makes sense you know but
then again Violet Davis is going to
still be Amanda Waller and uh John Cena
will still be Peacemaker and those
things are in C Josh mundall chat
reminded me to promote the stash
reservist list thank you Josh you go to
Jane Silent Bob secret stash friends do
you have a comic book store near you if
not man why not order your comic books
like Mark's mace forthcoming Mace Windu
comic book from Jay and Silent Bob
secret stash become a reservist we'll
send Comics anywhere in the continental
United States um go to jany bob.com for
more details thank you Josh mall for
that anyway back to what we were talking
about Lobo mimoa is perfect for Lobo
yeah um later on in this variety piece
it says at least two of Amber herd
scenes were cut from Aquaman 2 an action
sequence had found Meera fighting Black
Manta and a love scene with mimoa
according to individuals familiar with
the production she's probably fighting
black man to save her baby right and so
that scene's been cut which it's like
tonally does anybody want in fantasied
in their Aquaman movie not after the
first movie which was just candy colored
fish things and underwater fire I mean
could you imagine like Aquaman one hey
here's an octopus playing drums Aquaman
2 is a dead baby floating at the top of
this
T somebody somebody fish that out
somebody get the net and fish it out
like I didn't know this is the movie we
were going to
get um I'm not like I'm not saying I'm
all for baby killing Bing stretch to the
imagination Mark uh I know that's a hot
take but I'll say it right here that
being said that would not make me leave
that movie I would not be on my feet and
like how dare they I'd be like wow this
[__] took a [__]
turn like I gotta see what they do next
like of all the Cinematic bad guys I
believe Black Manta now Takes the Cake I
mean at least you know Thanos was like
half of everybody I'll never meet him
you know just [__] what did he say
about it he was like fair or some such
[__] balanced balanced but [__] when
you're just like killing babies [__] man
I mean that's that's I could see why
Warner Brothers was like perhaps no
although I will also say and and some of
it is always context right I in Battle
Star Galactica the miniseries I kept
watching it because they killed a baby
in the first five minutes of that show
when C six when Trisha helper's walking
through that outdoor mall and she's like
oh look at the baby oh they're so small
and fragile and she just sticks her hand
in there and you
hear like I'm watching this I gotta see
what they do next if they kill the
[__] baby teaser I forgot about that
that was so [__] Crimson you heard
the like little snap and [__] and at
first you were like what the [__] but
then it's like well they're about to
drop a bunch of missiles right it's
actually Mercy
in showing a little bit of Merc Mercy
but like that that intrigued me enough
to to to keep watching a 4our miniseries
but after the again the the weird like
Wonka Vision version of Aquaman you get
in in part one to be like by the way
part two killing babies now not just
babies your hero's baby and like I get
it it's in the comics but the Aquaman
Comics were not quite as
frothy uh as that movie was Bobby Hill
in chat said hey Kev everyone has been
talking about Obie being he who remains
for weeks Bud yeah I guess but this was
exposed to me here in [__] chat um so
strange what people choose to like like
that stuck in his crawl enough where he
was like I gotta write a comment about
this yeah like there's Glenn Alexander
in chat is like Mark have you read Dune
the book Paul's first son gets killed
I'm not saying you can't kill people's
Sons yeah like I mean granted it's awful
but I'm not saying you can't do that in
fiction you always always do that in
fiction but it needs to be part of the
story that feels like it's the story you
were always telling and Aquaman does not
feel like it's a story that was going to
hold INF fantacide um that's it's a it's
a turn and a pretty harsh turn at that
for the tone that you got in the first
one I'm all for stories that go [__]
dark when they when it feels like a
story that's going to go dark but I
don't know it just I could see like
because the first one played like a kids
movie and it's that's a that's a that's
a serious left turn for a kids's
franchise yeah
again Giant Octopus playing
drums um yeah that movie sounds and how
the the first one made a billion dollars
yeah like an Aquaman movie that made a
million dollars like that's nuts I mean
it makes sense in retrospect but like
nobody saw that
coming um and the fact that you do that
and then like you make another one and
it has all this trouble getting to the
[__] screen man it's
crazy yeah I don't I don't understand it
but very talented filmmaker too yeah
James Juan um but I think you know some
of it is also the watch word that James
gun keeps saying is if script's not
right we're not setting a date for it
we're not starting production all these
things tend to go wrong because they
have either no script or a bad script
but they're fenced in by production
commitments I guess they had to make an
Aquaman movie at some point and so they
made one and it's
bad
um Craven Knight on the in chat said
just watch that Battle Star scene wow
yeah it's intense
I remember talking to uh to to Ron Moore
because we had him on the Battlestar
galacticast a couple of times and asked
him about that and he was like yeah
sci-fi did not want to let us do that um
and for a very long time that scene did
not have the sound of a baby's neck
snapping it's like I Think We snuck it
in it's like I think we just snuck it in
like the last round of post Andi didn't
get a chance to bounce
it um somebody said that uh the crow is
officially been cast and it's the scars
guard kid yeah yeah I think we hit that
yeah we hit that a couple like a month
ago or so it's not it's not new news I
that man I think he's a good
cast yeah I mean [__] it I'll go for it
I mean he's no Brandon Lee but sadly
nobody is um as Aquaman has all this
[__] trouble um Barbie became Warner
Brothers highest grossing film ever
right
yeah yeah higher than any
Batman higher than any uh Harry
Potter and I don't think they had her
signed to a sequel so that's going to
cost
them if she even has anything else she
wants to say about Barbie Tully Quinn in
chat said Remember When Hawkeye killed
that chicken in the mash finale he
didn't kill the chicken
remember I don't so in the mash finale
there's like they're trying to be quiet
and
uh there's uh if I remember correctly I
know Hawkeye didn't do it I think he
witnessed it and he talks about it and
he breaks down
emotionally um a woman who had like a
crying baby and if I remember correctly
they're hiding from aggressors in the
midst of war and uh he tells the story
that she was holding a chicken and the
chicken was clucking and so she killed
the chicken to keep it quiet but then
later on spoilers in the
episode they Ral it was not a chicken
that she was holding but a child and you
know that was that was in the mash
series finale
dude you know what I'm saying like we're
wrapping this show up like [__] a
40-year successful run and let's leave
him with good feelings they like P.S
this happened as well well yeah by the
way that's that's a tough
one um TR train said Kevin stop reading
chat we're all insane in
here insane over here too kids word them
up infinite mush goes Mash wow yes I
know why are we we're really deep
digging far [__] back man people like
Ryder strikes over you guys talking
about [__] the mash series finale
watched programs in TV history indeed uh
meanwhile uh Matthew vaugh uh was at
director Matthew Von he of um the kman
series first class KCK ass uh was at New
York ComiCon um just kind of just
spinning wisdom in front of a crowd and
talked about his first experience in the
X-Men universe and how badly it went and
he talked about how X-Men the Last Stand
did Hollyberry dirty um he said that uh
he was attached to direct X-Men 3 and he
said I went into one of the executives
offices and I saw an X3 script and
immediately knew it was a lot fatter I
was like what the hell is this draft and
the executive went don't worry about it
and I'm like no I'm the director I'm
worrying about this draft the executive
wouldn't tell him so V grabbed it he
said and I opened the first page and it
said Africa storm kids dying of no water
she creates a thunderstorm and saves all
these children and V says well I thought
it was a pretty cool idea but once he
learned what was going to happen to the
script his relationship to the project
sour vgh said what is this and they said
oh it's h Berry script I went oh okay
because she's not signed on to do the
movie yet and the executive goes but
this is what she wants it to be and once
she signs up we'll throw it in the bin
the director
said and V's like well you're going to
do that to an Oscar winning actress who
plays Storm I'm out of here so I quit
the
movie that's [__]
up I mean you know I should really close
my mouth um I'm acting like that Mark
that is the single worst thing I've ever
heard but it's pretty
[__] tricky tricky Dicky it's it's a
little skey it's a little like I don't
want to play the race card but it's a
little [__]
racist like I know what halberry wants
she wants to be in Africa and save like
hungry thirsty kids um like and also
that they we're gonna we're gonna
commission a script that would have no
intention of shooting just to get her to
sign on is uh is some shyy
[Music]
nonsense good for uh Matthew vaugh for
spilling the tea as the kids used to say
right as the kids used to say granted
like Matthew vau it's good for him for
saying you know what I won't do that to
this actress that seems really [__] up
and if you guys are going to do that I
don't want to be a part of it when he
did sign on to X-Men first Class they
had a character named
Darwin um played by
Ed gei I think is how you pronounced his
last name uh but his whole power was
like I uh I can adapt to
anything and uh and then they kill him
like so the first of these young X-Men
you're going to kill is a black guy who
can adapt to
anything
really really come on
guys they just never learn you never
learn um but
anyway um hey while I'm thinking of it
you know I'm sitting uh this brick wall
behind me kids uh I'm at the world
famous improv in the 80s um um you're
watching USA Network and I'm about to do
all night I'm about to do a set yeah
it's Friday night at 1 am hb's young
comedy be along very shortly catch a
rising star kids right here catch a
rising star in
the8 um I am at SM Castle uh Cinemas
here in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey SM
Castle is right below me and in SM
Castle right below me on November
3rd we got two great filmmakers
coming coming to SM Castle I'm gonna
interview them who are they who are they
why it's the Russo Brothers mark That's
Right Joe and Anthony Russo are coming
here man for a nice
chitchat about their their lives and
careers and magical movies that they've
made tickets on sale right now at SM
Castle cinemas.com go scap up your
tickets man it's be a hell of a night
chitchatting with the Russo Brothers man
think about it very nice winter
soldier Civil War Infinity War all the
wars no endgame probably secret
War lots to talk about with the really
good guys man the gy
man yes yeah as well as all the [__]
they've been doing on you know [__]
Netflix with their
extractions app what's their company
called Aba agbo agbo um really nice
dudes who I've spoken to a few times
over the years I I [__] love those
two Avengers movies I make no apologies
for that [__] I mean Sito sit not really
a hot take I'm like I like both those
[__] Avengers movies people like
everybody likes those [__] the biggest
movies of all time yeah like holy [__]
are you sure you want to say that I'm
like oh yeah I'll say it right here now
on Beyonce's internet you're GNA say
that hey B man what's up if we were in
the MCU you know what today is today is
the day that Tony Stark saved half of us
so is that right so all of Avengers
endgame took place in 2023 I guess
because of the fiveyear jump yeah that's
what that's what everybody on the
internet was saying October 17 2020 3 is
Tony Stark day this is the day that he
[__] pulls all the gems off of
thanos's Fist and [__] dies for all
of us God damn it he took such a [__]
punch man like right before I mean I
know it's all fictional and
[__] Thanos isn't even real but uh he
[__] you know when he when he goes
for those gems that like last time
before Thanos you when he's like I am
inevitable and he goes to snash watch
that [__] watch how hard Thanos
[__] punches that [__] guy yep
again I know we're talking about like it
was a fight a boxing
match none of the shit's real but it's
it's [__] nuts man like two some of
my favorite moments in both of those
movies involve people fighting [__]
Thanos um you know naturally of course
the [__] you know Captain America
picking up mulling year is magical and
[__] but also [__] Captain Marvel
fighting Thanos where
he headbutts her and she don't even [__]
she headbutts right back yeah oh God so
awesome um you took everything from me I
don't even know who you are oh [__]
that's another magical
moment you took everything from me I
don't even know who you
are you will and she almost [__]
killed him man yeah she's the one didn't
[__] rain fire that was it she was
she [__] took all his clothes off and
[__] she raised him in the air and took
his clothes off she was like look at his
little dick she was going to shame him
first everyone looking up in the air and
seeing that purple little set of nuts
hanging out and then she was gonna
[__] crush him and [__] if I was her
with all that magic power if I'm the
Scarlet Witch like I'm like a few
minutes away from becoming the Scarlet
Witch and I still have all that power
and I hate that [__] Vision killing
piece of [__] I would have [__]
raised him up in the air ripped off his
clothes like she did then ripped off his
dick magically shoved it in his mouth
before he had a chance to rain fire yeah
that's what I'm gonna talk to the Russo
Brothers about Mark when they come to SM
Castle November 3D you think that fos
knows what a Colombian necktie
is here's where you guys [__] up okay
I've been waiting to say for years
Scarlett wit should have ripped thanos's
dick off shoved it in his
mouth first let me tell you about
Columbia Thanos
here's what they would do all the time
they're like wasn't it enough that Thor
cut his head off I'm like no no easy he
killed gamor cut his dick off and shove
it in his
mouth
um all right um moving on yes guo Del
Toro um revealed that he was wanted to
make a Star Wars movie about Jabba the
Hut yeah I read that that would have
been fun uh you know not that long ago
in this galaxy guro hoped to make a Star
Wars movie um but he wanted to tell
about the franchise notorious crime Lord
Jaba the Hut um blah blah blah blah blah
yeah apparently you know he wanted to do
the rise and fall of Jabba and his team
designed a great world full of great
stuff that dor was very happy with but
it never went into development
ultimately because it's not my property
it's not my money and it's one of those
30 screenplays that just goes away
basically Lucas film didn't like it
enough to put it into
production which you know listen I get
like as much as there's a version of of
you know if you give me an episode of a
TV show that is just the Jaba story sure
to spend a hundred million dollars on a
feature film about Jaba the
Hut not every character needs to be the
hero that we all get to see I'd have
been there I'd have gone for that one
but I'm with you I would have much
rather watched the series though Matthew
Herer herard he guardi in chat says
technically they killed the Thanos who
hadn't done all the things they blamed
him for yet well technically they killed
both Thanos they killed the Thanos that
[__] snapped everyone out of
existence and then they killed another
Thanos who to be fair was not innocent
yeah he did lot of awful [__] already
yeah he just hadn't done the snap yet
but was trying to as we saw the [__]
very end and
[__] I get I know this poops back but
God remember how hard he punched Tony
[__] Stark just go back and watch
that remember mind watching [__] you
know six kill a baby in Battle Star
Galactica go back and watch Thanos punch
[__] Tony Stark Man how he lives
through that hit I'll never know
probably because they're both
fictional but you know the physics of
that punch yeah it's fake physics at
best I can't believe we got away with
talking about a gamma the turo [__]
jobish Series without B man jumping in I
know seriously what what do you think
bman B the way I would have done it
is like uh four
rooms where you're Jaba is the Anchor
Point and you use different aliens in
his court and you tell their stories
about why they're in the court like the
old school book Tales From jabas
Palace I think that could be very
compelling that's how
I lcas film will never hire me for
anything but that's how I do Sam um or
you get they just did you're doing a
comic book well Marvel hired me
lucasfilm just didn't bounce
me um in chat Big T
1377 said Tony Stark built this in a
cave with
scraps there's a there's a great
anecdote in the uh in the MCU book about
how dismayed Jeff Bridges was on the set
of Iron Man because like he thought
there was a script when he showed up to
go to work he like almost every day was
Ferro and Downey huddled in a trailer
for like five hours inventing that day's
work and Jeff Bridges is just like
playing games with the crew on set and
he's like how do you make a movie like
this what is happening it's always been
like that at Marvel from the jump where
it's
like we like Downey just wouldn't like
what they were shooting that day so he
and favro would just figure it out as
they went and there's a great anecdote
where at one point Ferro was like you
know what I think we're going to kill
all this cave stuff at the beginning of
the movie and the production designer
was like John we built the cave we're
shooting the cave it's like oh all right
we built the cave so I guess we'll shoot
that stuff and that's the heart of the
movie yeah him and and and yson and like
learning morality and all of that stuff
was gonna go until somebody just
literally like we've already spend
millions of dollars building this cave
we're shooting the
cave
okay
did you read that book I did I uhhuh how
fast to read was it um it was an
incredibly fast read because I'm deeply
interested in subject matter and a lot
of it was you know I have been also a
careful Observer of Marvel uh low these
past 15 years sometimes as a journalist
sometimes as a watcher and like there
was the stuff that I thought I knew
pretty well the stuff that I kind of
like thought I understood but almost
every chapter there's a thing that I
just didn't know that like was
previously hither to withheld from
frying eyes um it's it's an
extraordinary piece of work um so yeah
yeah I highly recommend
it um I gotta tell you man it could be
what Marvel you know everyone's like
Marvel Marvel's this Marvel's that could
be what Marvel's been missing is just
Robert Downey Jr sounds like he did a
lot of free
writing get that guy back in a writer's
room it'll only cost you $50 million
more than not how much did you say one
five or 0 0 yeah you're right about that
that's for sure and I'm telling you man
if they want him back it's probably
gonna be 100 and they crazy not to pay
it at this point I mean you know there
are all the rumors of what secret Wars
is you know either it's some version
from the comic book that we know
whatever it is but it's an opportunity
for them to dip back into that [__]
well and just give us the things that
they've not been giving us for the last
you know five years or so and like would
they spend $100 million to get Robert Dy
Jr back for one movie for three scenes
in one movie yeah yeah they will will
Chris Evans decide like hey you know
what I want to take one more swing with
this Shield like you know what fine what
do you want
what do you
want you know and then that also lets
them recast things in continuity that
also lets you recast you know hey we
want a different Thor now hey we we want
a different Tony Stark now we still want
him to be in the movies but now as he's
being played by I don't
know whomever pick a
dude M Molina 2121 in chat says if the
MCU doesn't move into X-Men and
fantastic for soon no one will
care um he's I mean I'm not saying he's
right 100% but they they really should
[__] start playing their X-Men cards
and their Fantastic Four cards you know
I mean I think Fant all I keep reading
about is like they're gonna reboot at
Secret Wars but it's like yeah well
that's
[__] that's years from now I mean you
gonna staunch the bleeding before then I
mean our our our friend of the show Matt
shakman is directing Fantastic 4 and
according to him 've already cast it
like it's not even a matter of you know
we're not sure it's like no we know who
the cast is they're not announcing it
while the actors are still on strike but
they know who it is oh is that right
yeah um as for X-Men like it's the one
thing they actually have to get perfect
um it's the thing that everybody wants
and has always wanted um and so like
take your
time absolutely take your time like do
not rush it um which you know if if it
was my money and I know it's not and I
know how hard a thing it is to do but I
feel like they should have just taken a
break after endgame like endgame is the
end of that story and the minute we come
off of end game with other movies with
other characters it's like no this is
not actually what we want we actually
want it to stop we want it to feel like
an ending because that's the ending um
and then give it a couple of years of
not having [__] superheroes in our
faces and then come back strong whether
that strong is Fantastic 4 whether that
strong is X-Men whether that strong is
Deadpool 3 which then leads you into the
X-Men I don't know but you know I liked
Shang Chu just fine I didn't really care
that much about Doctor Strange to the
internals was whatever um nothing that
has come out since has been like amazing
other than the Sony stuff other than the
Spider-Man
stuff and like but hey again we're just
we're just armchair detectiving which is
armchair Studio
running it's all
dreamy uh what else we got on the news
side uh we got uh a couple stories out
of New York Comic Con um first off Tom
Hardy is getting into comic books with
Scott
Snider um the two of them are teaming up
for a book called
arcbound with Hardy as the creative
collaborator is the title that he's
taking on it uh Scott SN is writing it
along with Frank tier um longtime Marvel
head 12 issue series takes place in a
future where Earth is a Barren
Wasteland uh the formal
corporatocracy uh harnesses the
unmatched energy of chronium to assert
its Dominion across the stars and the
arcbound series Chronicles the Journey
of Kai a Resolute mediator Captain
tasked with the maintaining of blah blah
blah blah blah um all of that stuff is
without context is just kind of wordy
word stuff but I like Scott Snyder quite
a bit I think Tom Hardy is a smart dude
um I'm
curious I'm curious um also out of New
York ComicCon um a new comic book
production company called ghost machine
was announced ghost machine comes from
Jeff John's
um Brad Meltzer um Lamont McGee uh Gary
Frank Brian hitch um Francis manipol
Peter J tamasi like it's something of an
All-Star collaboration between writers
and artists all of which um will Connect
into this vast Universe books are coming
out through image ghost machines and
production company that will already set
up these things um in in in other
media I mean Jeff Johns it's hard to bet
against that dude in comics and it's got
Brad Meltzer as well and Brad Meltzer is
super smart I love Brad meltzer's work
yeah um Lamont McGee the secret weapon
he was on um Black Lightning for the
entire run he did the Star Wars Jedi
Adventures um super deep
nerd I'll see what they're up to Heavens
yes Heavens yes yeah um and then finally
um you know it's been a couple of weeks
now but Keith
gfin yes passed away L Keith
gfin speaking of responsible for one of
the most fun comic book
runs in uh history they did the Justice
League the fun Justice League Justice
League America Justice League well
Justice League it was called and then
they did Justice League Europe Justice
League jli Justice League International
um created the you know uh Blue
Beetle the Hae
Rees well no but the blue beo Booster
Gold Team UPS in the
old Justice League you know Batman
punching Guy Gardner [__] knocking
him out one punch Jon Jones one punch
Oreos later on becoming choos and stuff
um yeah he wrote some amazing amazing
stories how old was he he was 70 years
old um did like co-create Rocket Raccoon
yeah created Rocket Raccoon again the H
Rees version of Blue Beetle he created
with with John Rogers and Raphael
Albuquerque um and cly Hamner um yeah
his the the announcement of his passing
was as I understand it I've never met ke
um but was perfectly in character where
uh on Facebook Wednesday uh the
Wednesday he passed there was a post
pre-written by gfin who knew he was
passing said quote I told them I was
sick anything not to go to New York
ComicCon thanks
bah oh he used Baha he did he did that
all the time in the Justice League
Comics yeah a stroke is being attributed
as a cause of
death what a talented guy wrote some
beautiful stories and and uh wasted my
some of my time in such in the sweetest
way thank you thank you man of words for
wasting my time in the best way possible
indeed what a legend he'll be missed man
right much thank but you know what glad
he was here because that incarnation of
the Justice
League one of my favorites I loved
reading that those stories issue after
issue
um Mark walrus onion in chat says Mark
Goddard who played Major West on Lost in
Space he
passed as did Phyllis coats the 1950s
Lois the first liveaction Lois Lane no
she also passed s of [__] as did Piper
Lori pass Piper Lori passed as well I'm
going to laugh at
you Car's mom also Twin Peaks also the
Hustler what actress she
was uh 91 right
yeah yeah yeah man such amazing life and
of course Suzanne Summers passed away
just this weekend
sadly
um battle with breast cancer yeah that
was the I didn't realize that was the
case CU I was like what she looked so
young even though she was like 77 or 78
she still looked incredibly young but uh
yeah apparently a b long battle with
breast cancer since like the year 2000
202 23 year battle she married to her
husband for like 55 years
man she was as famous as it got when we
were
kids yeah man I mean thre's company it's
hard to imagine today how big a show
company was it was like friends bro yeah
in terms of how [__] huge and popular
it was they got a lot of Seasons out of
it yeah like it's even like that that
show was huge at a time when every show
was huge you know it's hard to imagine
what those numbers were but there were
only three [__] channels and
everybody watching TV was watching one
of three shows at any given time so even
the 20th show in the top 20 was getting
14 15 million people watching it and
three company was a number one
show
um she was uh George DT pointed out
Suzanne Summers was 76 one day from
being 77 she died day before her
birthday Victor van diagram said did we
discuss Arlene sorcin in another episode
um I don't know if we ever did get to
yeah not sure aren sorin passed a couple
months back of course the voice the
original voice of Harley Quinn
who I interviewed on Fat Man on Batman
years ago lovely woman and uh you know
is largely responsible for Harley Quinn
even being created in the first place
Paul deie will tell you very true so yes
we lost her as
well
[Music]
um yeah man oh somebody said in chat as
a 90s kid uh F kusma said as a 90s kid
she will always be Carol Foster to me
that was from what step by
step
yeah I watch
that as a George Lucas kid she'll be the
blonde and the white teabird in American
Graffiti that's right before she was on
long before she was on thre's company
man she was the girl in the in the what
is it white T Bird or
something um yeah man gosh she worked
with George Lucas all those 70s people
knew each
other they were all
[__] uh Jim Tomlin pointed out we
missed another one Michael Gambon from
Harry Potter he passed away few a month
ago or while we were off making the
movie that's
true yeah
man why do all these people have to go
don't go time waits for no
person DJ said and the thigh th Master
that's right we didn't [__] that was
was a huge chunk of her [__] career
at one point was thank you Thigh
Master red comet said rip to rest in
peace to the best
Dumbledore um Michael
gamble
um like we talked about that because I
remember um what's his face Shan Harris
Richard Harris's son went on the record
saying that like you know my if anybody
could have picked up for my father like
my father always loved Michael gambal's
work um Richard Harris being the the
actor who originated the role on screen
of Dumbledore he was like he always
loved his work so we were all very happy
that he was the man chosen to Da the
little silly
hat um that all the News That's all the
news my friend there you go kids that's
all that's going on in this business of
show
um let's see uh Stanley and chat says
any live shows coming oh hell
yeah no idea when and Mark talking about
uh well I mean we'll probably be doing
one at the scum and villain Cantina
coming up in the next month talking
about coming out to to SM Castle in
November and doing a thing we're
figuring out dates yeah uh meantime of
course uh as previously mentioned the
Russo brothers are coming to SM Castle
November 3rd November 11th is the Zach
and Mary 15th
anniversary 15 years of Zach and muie at
smodcastle cinemas.com for tickets and
then December 2nd we have SM aution
which is just a whole auction you know
we do those auctions of props and
costumes and and sign lithographs and
[__] like that before big shows well
this is the whole show just in time for
Christmas um I got to go get a charger
because my my laptop is dying
so so Vamp will
you come in here and and Vamp Vamp with
Mark and uh let's figure out what our
questions are going to be indeed ask us
these questions
three um somebody in chat said American
Graffiti was not filmed in Modesto well
trivia I host trivia on Wednesday nights
I'll be hosting trivia tomorrow night uh
do you know where American Graffiti was
filmed because Modesto was too modern
here's also something crazy American
Graffiti was filmed in like
1973 74 about
1962 if we made American Graffiti today
it would be about the year
2010 can you imagine how much of the
world changed between 62 to 75 that you
can make a Nostalgia film that was only
10 years
old crazy yeah like what's what's the
Nostalgia that anybody has for like
2002 uh I mean I don't I don't think I
have any what do I miss about
2010 uh being in my
20s yeah I have Nostalgia over my knees
yeah remember when my back didn't hurt
just trying to stand up y that was
lovely remember I could eat whatever I
wanted to oh my God that's yeah yeah my
metabolism is what I would make my
Nostalgia about I know I'm powered up
kids you fired up powered up man um all
right let's do
this we'll start with this one because
we had two people asked to same question
uh both Robert Mills and Laura D wanted
to know uh what was our favorite
trick-or treat costumes growing up
[Music]
H well one thing I think you have to
remember about the life that one LED in
the
1970s is that by and large Halloween
costumes were just [__] Hefty trash
bags with appliques of muscles on them
um the techn the costume technology was
not advanced in the 70s um it was it was
either paper or plastic um I almost
never got like a customade costume my
mom was not that lady who was sitting
down with [__] sewing machine
patterns to figure out how to make me
into Oba Fett or whatever didn't happen
um but I think my favorite was probably
Batman only because I had a cape um and
cap capes with a [__] even though that
Cape was made of plastic um and snagged
on everything um I'm going say
Batman what was the question again
Growing
Kids go ahead oh growing up your
favorite trick-or treat
costume I mean I remember like a lot of
like
kids
were
bums
remember like you'd burn a cork and youd
put like a [__] like five o'clock
shadow on you and you wore ratty clothes
and you carried a bindle
stiff um I remember I just remember that
a lot
like um my favorite outfit I think we
ever did was me and Bellos Mike
bellicose
made
Ghostbuster um outfits and
our own proton
packs and they the outfits were so
[__] good that Bell CO's brother
older brother Timmy and uh his friend
one of his friends borrowed them for
like Henry Hutson senior dress up day
[__] they're pretty good outfits more I
think about it like me and bells did a
really nice
job um but I like I like those outfits
those was probably the best Halloween
cost I've ever had in my life I was
vman I uh I dressed as Voltron when I
was like six and that was pretty cool
you and a couple friends or just you by
yourself I just me by myself it was me
and my brother my brother was a pirate I
think not like just generic pirate and I
was Voltron uh lion Voltron not vehicle
Voltron um although well yeah my
favorite Halloween costume of all time
may
be uh two years ago we dressed my
daughter up as the staypuff marshmallow
man when she was like 11 months old and
I went as a Ghostbuster and that was
pretty cool that's dope but I had like
money so I bought the big Proto I I went
full out for it you know you didn't make
yours out of cardboard box no I was 40
years old when I went so I I hit
shouldn't it technically have gone the
other way shouldn't she have been a
Ghostbuster and you were the state Puff
Marshmallow
Man yes although she has like the
chubbi that would have made a lot of
sense but chubby Baby Wise I could see
yeah he Michelin man that
kid let's see uh keeping with the
Halloween
theme uh what's the movie that scared
you the most as a kid and what's the
movie that scared you the most as an
adult that's from Shelby
Fielding say again scariest uh movie you
saw when you were a kid scariest movie
you saw as an
adult scariest movie I saw when I was a
kid
um when I was a little kid it was
[Music]
um was it don't be afraid of the dark
with little creatures that lived in the
baseboard were like always
Whispering they would
whisper and like they [__] the lady
shrinks down and is captive with them
for all eternity at the end of the FL it
was a TV movie oh damn
terrifying
um but uh The Shining erased that for
me uh as a kid the two twin girls in The
Shining still unnerve me to this
day um and as an
adult I mean nothing that scares me but
one of the most unnerving scenes
I remember from like
a quasi horror movie um there's a movie
with Jeff Goldblum called Mr
Frost where he plays the devil
essentially he's a guy in an insane
asylum with Kathy Baker I think her name
is and uh he is uh like he maintains
he's the devil and she's like yeah right
and then over the course of the movie he
kind of proves that he is uh but there's
a at one point she's watching a
video um of I guess either child abuse
or a child killing and God this is
horrible this is the second time this
come up in
the [__] show today uh but uh it's
her face Kathy Baker's face while she's
watching this thing you don't see the
thing you just see her turn a TV on that
goes from static to this image then cuts
to her face and she's watching and you
just hear this kid very like lightly
crying and instantly she [__] like
like she she plays it I'm I'm doing it
I'm not doing it justice the horror in
her
face like told the story way better than
any Grizzly image would have and she
shuddered and started crying and stuff
that always stays with me because it's
like you never saw what they saw you
know when we were kids we had Faces of
Death and [__] like that and the older
got the more you realize oh they made up
a lot of that [__] it wasn't and this
was made up too but my God it just
[__] it chills me the [__]
out
there um The Exorcist was the scariest
movie that I saw as a kid um I remember
seeing it I must have been like 12 or
13 and held such disain for it I was
like it's [__] this movie was made
the same year I was born how scary could
it be and then I watched it and you know
it's it's the kind of horror that that I
remembered I Remember Loving in the way
that one loves horor in that it was
almost entirely cerebral it was never
the the gore that got me was never the
the the viscera that got me was always
the the intellectual of it the like just
thinking about the the what possession
is what possession
means and that idea of of you were not
in control of your own body you're not
even a passenger anymore um I just
remember it frightening the [__] out of
me um like I was hiding behind a couch
building like a pillow fort to keep the
movie further away from me um because I
was an adorable kid
1983 um today you know like I I am not a
horror movie person I've I've I've
exclaimed that to the to the to the
highest that I just I don't I do not
enjoy um jump scares I do not enjoy the
that that
feeling um so like The Money Pit is a
movie that scares me today the idea is
like oh [__] real estate horror like I
bought a house that I thought was going
to be great and I end up sinking a
fortune and Sanity into it yeah that's
scary to me you know
like you know Falling Down is a movie
that's scary to me there there are
documentaries that are scary of like oh
yeah no this is the world you guys by
the way we are barely hanging on
um but but yeah because I'm not a hard
person it's not it that that is not a
that is not an itch that I try to
scratch um the world can be scary
enough yeah Victor van diagram said Wall
Street where the bad guy becomes the
hero to an entire generation of people
yeah like fight Club is scared you know
like I remember seeing that movie like
three years ago um for the first time
since it was in theaters like oh [__] no
this is just how terrorists get made oh
this is just this is just like
unchecked you know aimless rage oh okay
I get it yeah this is awful The
Joker The Joker for me I watched that
like during the pandemic and I was like
oh my gosh this just feels
irresponsible film ramblings with hero
004 said Kevin Tony had made contact
with the gauntlet and taken the Stones
by the time Thanos punched him he was
using the power of one of the stones to
take the power of the punch you buy
that uh I don't buy Tony Stark knowing
how to modulate and employ the use of
individual
Stones the minute he gets it granted
he's a very smart guy but I don't I
don't I don't quite buy that I think he
just took a [__] shot to the chops um
and the suit has some impact resistance
and shock absorbing natures and all that
[__] it is a suit of armor after all but
still
still um you know what's [__] scary
funny games did you ever see that movie
oh [__] you're absolutely right it is
that is a terrifying and unnerving movie
both versions both
Michel and the Remake are [__]
terrifying um how those kids like
address the camera how they are just
with the family but then when they
address the camera gets even more good
good call that is a [__] unnerving
movie you know because it is just like
we're going to do violence because we
want to do violence and nobody asked for
it nobody [__] walked into it like
nobody did anything wrong it is just
chaos arriving in your house and you
can't do anything about it that [__] is
frighten I uh I was terrified as a kid
nightmares terrified of
Labyrinth I think I watched it too young
and just Goblin puppets just absolutely
scared me and it was like I I probably
saw it when it came out on video so 86
or 87 so maybe I was five or six years
old and it was like real like the goblin
could come and actually take you um and
I had a baby sister it was yeah
Labyrinth and then uh I went I made the
mistake of going to the movie theater to
see Event Horizon when that came out oh
[__] that [__] scene of Madness
that's oh wow that was a mistake uh
because I thought it was a sci-fi movie
I do not like horror movies at all um
like Mark they gotcha and uh yeah I was
like wait yeah at about 45 minutes into
that movie I was like oh this is a bad
idea yeah yeah and again there are
movies that I you know I've never seen
it
follows um but I like the idea is
frightening like you know what good
enough I get it fine
uh I will grant you that that's probably
scary um else you know who I saw in the
picket line who leslieanne
Warren from clue clue Miss scarlet and I
was like I loved you in clue and she was
walking and you know she's she's a woman
of a certain age but uh I was like I was
at my friends movie theater and we
programmed it and an audience of like
200 people laughed their asses off she
was like a your heart thank you
rock um all right last
question we go kids last question of the
evening man this is from uh ear Mixon
wants to know on jml midnight in chat no
jml in chat says midnight showing of The
Blair Witch the week could
open remember remember that [__] end
of the movie where Mike is facing the
wall and she's just Heather is just
screaming and [__] oh my God I was in
Sun I started Sundance you were there I
was there for that for that year and
like the mixture of no idea what it was
plus like thin atmosphere and exhaustion
like
[__] I have told this story many times
but uh John Pearson who repped uh was
the producers rep on
clerks one of my dear friends uh he was
involved with the Blair Witch kids that
started kind of as a short on his show
uh split screen they kind of showcased
the legend of the Blair Witch there
before they finished the movie for uh
you know um who put that out wasn't
Lion's gate
um
um they don't mirax right was it mirax
or New Summit I forget it's company I
don't
think was it Li's k no what was the name
of that Artis and AR in the
US they don't exist anymore they were
like they were kind of a quasi mirax uh
almost a 24ish of their time Artisan
made like kind of classy movies any
event that yeah that was [__] that
[__] was the story I've told before
Pearson repped that movie so he had
given me a copy on VHS and I hadn't
watched it and so they went to
Sundance and the buzz out of Sundance
was huge and um Jennifer schwabach who I
was like in a brand new relationship
with at that point she was like you know
I I've I told her I was like hey man
there's all this Buzz about this movie
called The Blair Witch Project we have
it on VHS do you want to watch it
tonight and she was like yeah okay and
so we started watching it and I fell
asleep I was just not because of the
movie I was just tired and [__] um
although the movie is not like you know
[__]
keep you awake it you know PLS along in
the beginning and stuff so I fell asleep
watching
it and I
get woke woken
up by the end of the movie by a
hysterical Jennifer Schwab he's like oh
my god get up get
up and I was like what what what F
what's happened what happened and she
was like these kids what's going on like
why won't anybody help them and I was
like what what do you mean and she's
like why won't anybody help them like
they were how could this [__] happen
why won't anyone help these kids and I'm
like this this movie's not real and
she's like what and I was like this
isn't [__] real it's just make
pretend this it just looks real because
this is one of the first found footage
movies right so she's like I believe you
I was like I can call John Pearson man
he'll [__] tell you the same thing I
was like [__] [__] you ask Stan grman
he'll tell you the same [__] Fargo
[__] and so she was like [__] and I
was like I called up John Pearson who
was at Sunday and I was like John like
[__] Jennifer is freaking the [__]
out she just woke me up because she
thinks Blair Witch Project is real I was
like can you talk to her and he said
yeah I'll talk to her and I handed her
the phone I couldn't hear their
conversation but all I heard was her
going
John why won't anyone help
and and then there's silence and he goes
she goes are you sure she goes I don't
believe you and and silence and then
she's like
oh she's like and the other she go I
get it was it was [__] over 20 years
ago this happened I hear you but I'll
never [__] forget her being
like why wouldn't even help them that's
how [__] that's how realistic that
Blair Witch Project movie was she
[__] [__] out of it
man even help
them like it broke her brain like we're
watching a movie where these [__]
kids are being imperiled but nobody will
help them and I'm like yes like didn't
you piece all this
together um all right what's our last
one last one uh you told me that it was
real I did in the beginning I was like
this
you're I was like this is a real
documentary let's watch it good night
and I fell asleep
watching help
them
John um okay what is it uh shifting
gears completely ear
Mixon uh if you could make any character
from Comics Speaker of the House who do
you
pick
I mean Captain America or Superman are
my top two
choices um because you know what they
keep telling us in the news this job is
makes you [__] second in line to the
presidency or third in line to the
presidency so I would want somebody
third in line to the presidency that you
know historically we could
trust aair
scrupulous moral
character so you got uh one of those
cats although I'm tempted to make Batman
the house Speaker you'll never see him
no where is he come out of nowhere and
[__] it would hit hard yes the
congressman from Gotham uh does he gonna
say not today um hands down I I I I say
Superman although Superman used to be
about truth justice the America way and
now he's like truth justice and get out
of my way no they Chang what is what
it's not the American way now it's just
truth
justice and the and uh and let's say
justice
again and even more
Justice my left hand is truth my right
hand is
Justice
um what about you um you know like
there's there's the ideological way to
go which I feel like the the Steve
Rogers version is pretty strong um but I
I I'm feeling either like
RoboCop or or Dr Manhattan you are in
violation
of vote now where there will be trouble
Dr Manhattan oh that'd be badass you
know like some I said leave me home they
all go
away teleports [__] both houses some
place where is he now he's on Mars but
he's also here and he's also voting but
he's also redefined
democracy uh Hey man we can't uh Finance
the government if the [__]
government's not here where did he send
him like he sent him to Mars to a
Crystal Palace so they can sort out
this [__] he hit him with the [__]
real
gavl I like robocup I think Alex Alex
Murphy um he's seen some [__] about some
[__] um knows him know knows what to buy
for a dollar and what not to buy for a
dollar um you know understands the way
the legal system works because it's been
written into his programming um as long
as he's not a pawn of of ocp of omni
consumer products I feel like he's a
he's an upstanding American and he'll
get it
done
from [__] artha Franklin from The
Blues Brothers you better think about
what you're trying to do to me you
better think like it also all those
proceedings
musical I mean I mean they could always
break out in a song it'll be like c rock
but for the House of Representatives so
weird you say that because that's the
first thing that went through my head
too I try I was building a coop Rock
joke and then I was abandoning it
because I was just like you know [__]
that would be dope man if [__]
like C-SPAN would be would become like
MTV time hearing she burst out in the
song and [__] house music all day long
House of Representative music it was
always you better think yes like all
right what are we trying to do to you
you try to pass this law that nobody
wants pass trying to put this motion
into motion too much motion don't
use to
me what about you B
man uh everything that's happening in
Congress reminds me of kind of like a
sarcastic reality show I think Deadpool
would be a great ring leader for a bunch
of
clowns I mean it'd be musty
TV whichever site you're
on Scott Levy said The
Punisher that is definitely a
choice hay wave said don't you blaspheme
in
here two whole Fried
Chickens he wants four Fried Chickens
and a
coke the one dry white
toast and the other wants four Fried
Chickens and a coke Jake [__] that's the
Blues Brothers Matt Guitar Murphy yeah
coming here like a couple htic Diamond
meres murf and the magic
[Laughter]
tones disain in his
voice murf uh what about you B man who'
you pick dead Pi Deadpool Deadpool oh
Deadpool that's right we did them all s
bper speaker Evan Fowler said in chat
bring me my cheese whiz
boy that was somebody who worked on the
show like casting director or costumes
or something like that that the guy who
says that in the Blues
Brothers of
crew
um the show band
danced danced
J2 K2 said jolia Jake and lwood
blues won't you welcome from citt City
Illinois the show band of Juliet Jake
and lwood blues the blues brothers
[__] they put cab Callaway in a movie
yeah
c not only they put him in the movie
they gave him a full ass [__] song
yes and he had and a huge part a
meaningful [__] part and this is a
guy who like was the King of The Cotton
Club at one
point so much so that yeah like when
they jump into that [__] dance you
know mini the MRA number that's that's
what his life looked like when he was
younger at the Cotton Club yeah the band
stand and the [__] three-piece tuck
and the top hat and all of the [__]
bandas and tuxes and everything could
you imagine like your cab Callaway and
you're like well you know I had my
moment and [__] you know cotton
club's gone and everything's different
now and you're in the 80s and [__] and
[__] like two of the hottest
comedians on the
planet come to you and they're like we
want you to do that thing that you used
to do we want you to do mini the mucher
like in this [__] giant [__] off
movie and we're going to make it look
like it did back when you were at the
Cotton Club like are you updating it at
all no we want you to do mini the mucher
the same way you would have done it in
1938 okay kind of beautiful like when
you think about you know they fought
them really hard they uh Dan award and
and John Landis and of course John
Belushi wanted to bring in all these
soul and blues Legends and whatnot and
um music legends and uh the studio of
course was like like they wanted them to
bring in the band that did Car
Wash which in arguably is a great
[__] slaming get me wrong car wash
but they had their own whole ass movie
and whatnot but uh you know these cats
Belushi and and
particularly Dan Aid and and I guess to
a lesser degree John Landis they wanted
like classic Legends they fought for him
and they got him and like you know
because the studio is like come on man
artha Franklin Ray Charles [__] cab
Callaway these people haven't had
[__] you know hits and whenever and
then artha Franklin went on to like hit
the charts again remember oh yeah who
zooming who and [__] like that I mean
and I'm sure it helped that that was a
relatively cheap movie despite
destroying every car that existed in
Detroit at the time
um you and they actually dropped a car
not in Detroit but in well I mean they
were in Chicago they went to
nearby [__] where did they drop that
car I want to
say it was in Chicago um I read about it
online but they dropped a car like
in dropped it for the Nazi car that
takes uh Michelle D in chat says cab
Callaway actually didn't want to do
Minnie the Moocher because he was
pushing a disco version of the song at
the same time so here we were going like
oh c Callaway must have been so excited
he was like you are [__] my disco
[__]
up I got these platform shoes I got the
[__] disco
ball Rose Royce that's who sing Car
Wash
um John Lee Hooker is just out on the
street does doesn't even talk just
little boom boom
yeah hey hey Carwash equals Rose Royce
the entire soundtrack the first of the
soundtrack album oh how how how rest in
peace Jordan Peters says rest in peace
to our princess Carrie fiser that's
right she was in there as
well Frank Oz as well Stephen Spielberg
Stephen Spielberg yeah Frank O T T Train
said Frank O is the Govern guy out to
lunch no Frank Oz was the guy you know
who's like one one prophylactic you when
he's checking out Jake in the he's the
evidence guy mustering them out of
prison and Spielberg is the guy who's
out to lunch that they gotta pay Cook
County assessor's office
[Music]
right come on
hey Stanley said did Kevin get an award
in Jersey I did I got from the mommoth
Arts folks I got uh momth Arts after
dark folks I got is it a sexy award yeah
I did it's where is it it's over there
but it's really nice piece of glass um
after dark and I'm getting another award
on Thursday from the good folks the
friends of firefighters which is an
event the gala event fundraiser event
I'll be hosting on the Thursday hey B
man put it up it's right
there help out who don't [__] love
firemen uh you want to help out some
fireman kids go bid you you bid on uh
win uh a birth if you will on The Good
Ship Jay and Silent Bob when we go Cru
es skew in February me and Mark will be
on it doing Beyond that's like four
months from now yeah it's coming close
man it's coming like Christmas and [__]
well after
Christmas um that's right kids four
months from now you can spend three days
on a boat with me and Mark and Jason
Muse Brian o holler Jeff Anderson Jason
Lee Ethan
S Jennifer schwabach Ralph
Garmin Andy melish the list goes on and
on Cru J and Sal Bob's cruises Q jbob
crues qq.com for more
details see me and Mark do fat man at se
in international
waters love fat man we're gonna get out
there and we're gonna have knife fights
and
[__] oh F man now look at that look at
those
cats who are those
clowns I don't know what's going on
there J put an ad up that's what it
looks like look at that look at look at
all the fun activities we got going on
join us on the high se's Kev kids Kev
yeah I was reading James B Smith said
Kev has owning a movie theater given you
a wider perspective on film and
storytelling n not so much on film and
storytelling because I spent a good
portion of my life inside movie theaters
long before I bought one it does as an
exhibitor make me very conscious of the
running time of movies
I used to never care I used as a
filmmaker I'm like hey man make a movie
as long as you want [__] or as short
as you want but you know it's usually
long movies that people complain about
um so I was never one of those cats I'm
like hey man it's your testimony do
whatever you want but now as a guy who
uh as a film exhibitor somebody who's
like making money off of movies that
play in his theater or not really the
theater the movies draw people in then
selling popcorn to those to those folks
that's where the real money is instead
now I now I'm like hyper sensitive to
running times of movies because if you
give me a three-hour movie [__] man
that's one less Showtime we got to earn
back that money and
stuff um keep them short that's what I
say welcome to killers of the flower
Moon how long is that movie 32
something
really all right all right all right I
can't argue with him man like scorsi uh
this kid he I think he's got a future in
film he seems to know what to do with a
camera I think he's gonna be around for
a long time so I'll give it a
shot almost four hours
wow Jose monster asked what movies did I
buy from Criterion well I'll tell you
but J I got the OG out of the Living
Dead I got
Wall-E uh Malcolm X The Princess Bride
Devil in a Blue Dress police Story one
police story two box set Silence of the
Lambs and Godzilla
1954 that's what you bought yeah I went
for
it um stoic Nick said it's called Cinema
LOL what just because it's long cinema
cinema Cinema's
long 24912 said wasn't Taylor's movie
almost three hours was that concert
movie very long I don't know I don't
know the running time of it I mean the
thing of it is if an audience likes it
it almost doesn't matter how long it is
and
clearly hundred million dollar any a
weekend it didn't hurt nobody wild
Samurai put in chat killers of the tiny
bladder it's good
joke Wally unrated yeah yeah jig me all
that people talking about the liveaction
Gargoyles that apparently there's
somebody
online let
slip yeah now Disney plus is making a
liveaction gargoyles TV show
which glad for them I uh I don't have
any GS love or hate it was just not my
jam yeah it was kind of after us a
little bit after Batman the Animated
Series if I remember correctly mhm super
Sean 064
in chat said the Marvel's only an hour
and 45
minutes seen a lot of stories I mean for
whatever this is worth take it with a
grain of salt that
uh says that uh their box office ain't
going to
be it's not tracking huge uh the Taylor
movie is two hours and 48 minutes
according to Mike
W it's a concert yeah if you're a
[__] fan that's that's a lot of
entertainment
um
well so we got anything
else I'm uh the the tank is empty the
cupboard is bare now people are just
repeating stories that we've already
done like Best Buy is gonna stop
carrying DVDs like we know gargoyles
with Keith David
yes
um
I'm trying to think see if there's
anything
else no no
yeah why it buts said killers of the
flower Moon made in Oklahoma they have
great film tax rebates
Rich good to know man guys did you watch
the boys gen V yet I have not is that
cartoon live action it's the it's the
college set I gotta try that out
um the uh let's
see Napoleon Movie says Virginia native
yes they've made
one really
Scott quack Phoenix not even trying to
do a French accent Rob yeah he's taking
the [__] Kevin cner and Robin Hood
approach hey yep it's like you know what
I can't do it it's going to sound weird
if I
try it's the it's the the Clooney Clo's
Boston in a perfect storm is
non-existent Right Robert Mills said
Keith David is horak you're absolutely
right man you're absolutely right
Masters of the Universe Revolution
coming at the top of
20124 I think there's a trailer coming
in
November geek
we that's right um ear Mixon said when
is your movie coming out my movie I we
just finished it just finished
shooting find out soon as I know I'll
tell
you believe me I'll be all over
that uh well there it is kids we did a
lot of lot of chitchatting Virginia
native said Invincible new trailer also
oh for season
two loved Invincible I look forward to
watching season two are they dropping
all the episodes at once I don't know
nothing about
toxy um have
they apparently it's screamed at
Fantastic Fest to rapturous reviews
response people liked it they seem to
have
yeah um that's uh um Peter Dinklage
right uh Seattle K says The Rocketeer is
also coming to Disney plus
what um it's it's a thing that's been in
the works for a while um Yello um
rock uh yeah where he plays like she
finds the rocket pack yeah I think he
plays like a former Tuskegee Airman and
she finds the rocket pack and they hard
a new writer for it but yeah it's it's
not a new thing there was just a a
little bit of momentum shift on it
but I'm here for it I love The
Rocketeer um Scott Pilgrim TV series
cartoon looks great trailer looks
amazing trailer looks good yeah and they
got the whole cast back all the voices
right it's like all the voices yeah you
know and I think they I remember
listening to a quote from uh from like
Edgar R and and and uh Brian leoi and
and Ben David kinsky who's they're all
producing it together so that one member
of that cast said no it would have kind
of scuttled it because we just didn't
want to recast anybody but everybody was
down and came in and get to play in chat
Evan Fowler says no two halves for
invincible season 2 one next month one
next year four UPS
each all
right uh Charles Palama asks what's your
favorite film you've screened at SM
Castle a great question you mean like
one of mine
or just
anything
you know maybe the Jersey Girl the uncut
Jersey girl yeah I hadn't seen that in
[__] ages and stuff Raquel came out
for it that was a good
time um all right
kids we've got uh all I hear Laura D
says all I hear about my house to my
teenager is Five Nights at Freddy's
going to the Almo Draft House for the
first time to see it that's a video game
right and they turned into a
movie um yeah I think I think I don't I
don't I don't know the I just remember
that my my son was all about five
minutes at Freddy's and I'm not sure if
you encountered it as a game or as like
a short or as some kind of viral online
thing um YouTube
whatever um I don't really know it
skipped me it went all the way past
[Music]
me
um James B Smith says as a big fan of
Chasing Amy will the documentary be a
good affirming watch yeah chasing
Chasing Amy which opened the mod Castle
second annual SM Castle Film Festival um
was uh really really great Sav did a job
with that
document um get schwifty said your
favorite Kevin is the moot one that
makes the theater money yeah I love any
movie that [__] sells out and stuff
like that um speaking of which Zach and
Mary Mega porno 15th anniversary
screening coming up but before that me
and the Russo Brothers November 3 get
your tickets now kids go to smodcastle
cinemas.com it's only about three more
events for smodcastle for the end of the
year there's the Russo Brothers there's
Zach Mary mea porno there's
Smokin
Josh mundal just pointed out that
Moonlighting is on Hulu now you were
talking about before we went right I was
yeah I watched the pilot and I was and I
haven't seen it in 30 some odd years
because I watched it first run um maybe
I saw reruns of the season the summer
that it had aired but like it had never
really I think it gotten a home video
released that I didn't bic is whatever
and I was astonished to discover that I
remembered every scene in that pilot and
that's a long than 90-minute pilot and
I'm like I remember this bit I remember
this bit oh he's gonna say this now I
remember like it this weird sense memory
of Moonlighting it's like oh yeah know
this is the finale when they have to
climb the ladder to get up to the to the
clock face at the the Eastern Standard
Building and she's going to hang on and
then he puts a lad but the ladder tips
and like all of it just kind of came
flooding back scene by scene by scene um
it's a it's a well- constructed
pilot um David
is and the pilot like that character is
not very well modulated so he's aot yeah
he's he's not quite the David Addison we
come to know and love Yeah like he's
he's kind of an [__] and kind of a
little toxic um too much it feels like
and even and syil Shepard is not also
understanding the sort of comedy of it
and so like it's it's a weird it's Proto
Moonlighting it's not Moonlighting yet
but like you see why they green L it to
a series you see you see the bones of
what it was going to be but it uh it
would take a little bit to get there
it's a fascinating watch Moonlighting
kids now available on Hulu took a while
to get there they had to change some of
the songs if I remember correctly yeah
music rights I think was a big
deal um which is a lot of the reasons
why some of your favorite shows aren't
on the air because the music the music
Deals they could cut um in the 80s and
90s are far different from the music
deals that you have to clear today and
so um it took a while and yet to your
point I think they did have to swap out
a couple songs to to get it through hey
kids here's something I never [__]
say don't you go ahead and smash that
like
button
o smash it why don't you go smash that
subscribe button
kids smash the like smash the Subscribe
do what
whatever I think we're GNA smash tonight
yeah man smash right now it's at 293 I
like this come on smash that like button
kids Smash It smash It smash
it you're doing it we're doing it we're
smashing T right
but I don't know what that gets us if
anything um there it is
kids do you have a good time did you
learn a thing or
two
well well that's because why is Kev
doing a bedtime voice lol am I what's my
bedtime did you get all sexy hey jul AB
Julian Abby says I've been subscribed
for 10 damn years that's right Julianne
you and
me get Smash Bros yeah Smash Bros um
there it is kids do you have a good time
well if you liked this and there'll be
more of this where this came
from uh Virginia native says freaking 2
am I'm bed I'm bedtime typing yeah it's
1:30 here in in the east
coast you're a soldier nin schwat says
Uh Kevin Smith After Dark that's right
Mike Ono said how is Kevin liking living
in the valley nice I like that I've
always been a big Valley kid I love the
valley man ever since I saw Bad News
Bears I was like I want to be in this
Valley you will you will have been glad
to miss this week because it's like 95
degrees this
week for reasons that you know it's the
end of the world so sure why not
October um it is uh yeah it's been it
was a beautiful like 630 uh
65 to 70 degrees here for the last few
days real nice nice now we're just
talking weather time to get the [__] out
of here man yep how's the weather by you
at morning couple old men discussing the
weather kid you had a good time if you
did because B man brought us right into
your [__] homes give it up for B man
there he is waving at you and [__] don't
forget uh this week uh I'm going to be
in Brooklyn the friends of firefighter
event a Gala uh at uh on
Thursday um and then uh I'll be back out
here on the East Coast for the Russo
Brothers on the 3 and Zach and Muay on
the
11th said hi December 2nd me and Mark
are gonna figure out when we're coming
back bringing it back bringing it back
maybe we'll bring a movie back too yeah
let's do that I know when you when you
when can you start like just selling
tickets for Splinter and [__] can you do
that are you allowed to do that or no I
can you know I think we're probably uh
at the end of the festival run um so I
mean [__]
like distribution for shorts is a weird
thing because hardly anybody does it
because there's very little money in it
but I know a guy with the movie theater
you know a do with the movie theater
$400 a ticket let's make some money
yeah it's a dollar a minute um $15
admissions dollar a minute everybody
wins um yeah man we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out definitely want to
come back East there's a Broadway show I
have to go
see I gotta hit the great white way
Gutenberg the musical oh yeah friend of
mine was asking me if I wanted to invest
in it but he hit me at a time where I
was financially
strapped um but they've also asked me to
come play for a day on that show oh you
should go the date that I'm going I'll
find out I'll find out when it is yeah
because uh one of my very best friends
wrote that play you should Brown yeah
really Scott Brown was my assistant at
Entertainment Weekly um uh he was an
awful assistant but a very good writer
um then went on to be the theater critic
for the for vulture I think for the for
New York Magazine then worked on a show
called Manhattan then worked on a show
called Castle Rock he's the guy who led
me to join the staff at Castle Rock he
made the introduction for me he wrote
the book for Beetlejuice bless you thank
you did he really he did and Gutenberg
is a show that he wrote when he was
working for me at at ew like it's been
15 years like I saw it off off off off
Broadway with him uh and his buddy
Anthony King in the starring rols and
they resurrected it 20 years later with
Josh Gad and Andrew Reynolds and so I
kind of I I I feel a moral and comedic
obligation to go see this play nice and
so uh it's GNA definitely be that week
that I'm back uh to do fat man so [__]
yeah um that's pretty dope right there
man um hey kids uh if you're if you like
the intelligent part of the show uh
that's
because Mr intelligence himself over
there he keeps it smart I keep it nice
and [__] dumb he keeps it
dirty um give it up for the great Mark
Bernard thank you doubt beisha in chat
says any interest in Back to the Future
of the musical and then right above him
Cur cat film says did Kev see the Jaws
Broadway play the shark is broken so two
plays on Broadway right now based on
Steph Spielberg movies Stephen Spielberg
is the king of the great white way very
much getting
paid House of Rio said thank you again
for making my patrol a lot easier
tonight well thank you for hanging out
with us there House of Ria indeed keep
an eye on CME thanks to all of you folks
for hanging out with us as
we pop the culture right in the [__]
mouth um there it is kids somebody said
am me go away says why no sponsors
nobody likes us yeah get cius yeah you
know the sponsor is tonight SM Castle
Cinemas yep SP Joy right below me man I
may be upstairs at the 80s improv in
front of this brick wall but right below
me is mod Castle Cinemas kids come see
the Taylor Swift movie come
see dumb money come see we're playing
Beetlejuice this
week um come on down come to SM cast of
Cinemas
kids sponsor of this year episode
of whatever we call this
[__] almost two o'clock in the
morning like what's going on this A Late
Late Late Late Late Show are we still
talking
go home uh there it is kids we'll be
back again before uh the end of the
month that's for damn sure because we do
have an ad and maybe we'll do it live
yeah we'll probably do it maybe we'll do
it in scum and villainy cantina so you
can sit there stand there and look at us
or sit there and look at us throw tissue
at us hit us real hard that's how drink
your drink your blue drink just have a
good Fu that blue milk tie one on with
blue milk start being honest and
[__] uh there it is my friends there it
is what else what else can I tell you I
could show you
this it's [__] gorgeous
book yeah heavy yeah it's bigger than my
head they put uh Guardian devil into
this oversized book that gorgeous
cassada and Patti artwork in oversized
pages that's available right get signed
to Jane Silent Bob secret stash become a
reservist at Jane Silent Bob secret
stash go to job.com for more information
kids we're gonna get the [__] out of
here it's 1:30 in the morning on the
East
Coast indeed gotta move my car before I
get a ticket can't park on First Avenue
past 2
am
yeah um there it is my
friends go be kind to other people in
this world go say something nice to
somebody close your laptop go say
something nice to somebody who deserves
it maybe say something nice to somebody
who don't deserve it maybe that'll flip
him around you know when I go out to eat
I used to work in restaurants when I was
a kid and so I always like to tip well
because as a bus boy I earned 15% of the
waiter or waitress's tips and [__] like
that so I've always been like a pretty
good
Tipper um my brother who's been in
restaurants his whole life um gets
irritated when ever I tip poor
servers like he's like I'm a [__]
waiter for a living and I can't stand F
like I why would you tip because I I tip
50% he's like why would you [__] tip
50% like that service suck I was like
because when I leave and that person
like sees that tip you know maybe maybe
they'll change their [__] ways or
something like that I don't know
so you never know man just go say
something nice to somebody watch the
trickle down you know some
people some people need to hear
something
nice maybe you're one them maybe maybe
you need to hear something nice here
I'll tell you something [__] nice
kids you are smart and
good very clever go give somebody
head
yeah wait
what did she say go get somebody head I
don't think that's what I was getting at
Mark but yes in
short um all right there it is my
friends uh for fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernard tune in next time
same fat Time same fat Channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com Kevin Smith
Jeff's kiss
everybody live long and
prosper this is the m greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA ask
keev anything every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and S Bob
get old up Kevin Smith J